hmm
[Music]
[Music]
all right hopefully everyone will see me
hear me
Adore Me
uh
ah
hope folks are having
a nice week
as we get
ever ever closer to the holidays
it is absolutely eggnog
what exactly is it you that you think
would pass for eggnog but isn't eggnog
that's very confusing to me as a concept
hello Miss Wicked Wolf hello uh carowind
hello vacuum comments Ben
um adrenaline homebody bookworm
Pirates Angus geek Rambles
uh lots of folks here good to see you
all
am I going to see Avatar uh the age of
water I maybe
I it's not I'm not in a rush I want to
try and get out to see Violent night
um
I really should have done that today
but I want to try and catch that one but
yeah I don't know I I'll I mean I'll
probably see a avatar eventually whether
I'm gonna rush out to the theater I
don't know
two of my best friends gave me an early
Christmas present beautiful Celtic cross
with Connemara marble oh that's lovely
Merry Christmas you filthy animal
I've butchered that quote properly
no that's that's the quote
um at least from the second one because
from the the first one it's keep the
change you filthy animal but then in the
second movie it's a different quote from
the same fake old movie well no from a
follow-up to the same fake uh old movie
franchise and in that one he goes Merry
Christmas to you filthy animal and a
happy New Year with gunshots in between
those two
so no you're still accurate just to the
sequel
Trek witch like that name counting down
to winter vacation for My Girls yep my
kiddo is going to be hitting it soon
have I seen Wednesday I have not I have
not had the time
um my mother has seen it
she liked it a lot
um and like she grew up on the original
Adams Family TV show so that was
interesting oh Michael Anderson Doyle
Dharma 12 months of joy and knowledge
glad you will thank you very much for
continuing to support as a member of the
channel greatly appreciate that
uh
see Donald Donald's got it and a Happy
New Year
uh uh do I have a favorite
who eczema special
um
it's one of those things that I would
probably give a different answer each
time I'm asked that at the moment it's
honestly probably
um
husbands of River Song
but that's you know for Capaldi and
River together
hahaha
Marv Harry why aren't you wearing your
shoes why are you dressed like a chicken
yeah yeah I know I know my home alone
I was watching Toy Story with my friend
the other day and I said the human
characters look less plastic than the
Kardashians that's a little cruel
I don't here's the thing
I don't care enough about the
Kardashians to have a negative opinion
on them
I just don't I just don't think they
matter enough to hate
and or was so good your analysis was
perfectly on point I found myself
wanting more of a Star Wars show than I
ever have in a long time yeah
Stargate yeah I I agree and or was
fantastic where did I get the cardigan
from this
um I can't I'm trying to remember if
this was a gift I think this was a gift
this was either a gift or I bought it
with a gift card
it's one of the two uh it's from it's
from Hot Topic because I don't know if
you can tell
I'm on camera that in some of the
sunflowers are skulls
so
they're kind of hidden in there
I'm getting to see them up at Christmas
Carol on the big screen next week
uh don't know uh
if it's the love is gone cut well it'll
be good either way
uh is Garfield my spirit animal I don't
think so I don't think I'm that lazy
my Boomer dad is worried about the
Russo Ukrainian War bleeding over onto
American Shores
what media would staunch his fears I
don't know because I don't know how you
get
there because
um
yeah I guess that would be a concern
given that America shares a border with
either
country
I like I'm not entirely sure what to do
with that
my favorite Christmas movie
it's honestly probably Love Actually
which I know like people have turned on
over the years I still like it
what's the most egregious Santa
franchise could commit for you I can't
give a blanket statement on that because
it's going to vary from franchise to
franchise because every franchise should
hopefully in theory be a little bit
different and so what would be uh an
unforgivable sin for one franchise might
be perfectly acceptable for another
depending on what they're built to do
and what kind of stories they tell them
what kind of characters they deal with
so I don't have a blanket answer for
that
I think I prefer the Christmas specials
to be given to guest writers to give
showrunners more of a break I mean maybe
never I hadn't thought of that
uh have I ever made anything from
scratch like Define anything
like food Yeah couple things not often
not usually
last week's disappointing Movie
experience finally went to see top gun
Maverick at a large UK chain we all sat
over 30 minutes with plenty uh with
plenty going to say it had not started
before we were told to oh that cut off I
guess is going to be continued later
hahaha
one of my favorite versions of Scrooge
Bob Cratchit and Jacob Marley all right
um
jeez
uh
I don't I don't really have an answer
for that I'm not I'm not I like I enjoy
A Christmas Carol but I'm not that
invested in it
uh let's see here oh Joshua uh
finzi thank you very much for the Super
Chat hi do you no longer identify as
gender fluid I only recently started
watching your vids again so I think I
missed a lot over the last few years no
I still identify as gender fluid I am
like I'm trans feminine so like my
general presentation is female so like
so
I am still gender fluid the range has
kind of narrowed
because so when I first came out as
gender fluid
I was at a point in my life where I
would have some days where I was feeling
masculine where I was feeling feminine
where I was feeling kind of neutral
non-binary sort of thing
over time that has shrunk down
specifically from the masculine ends so
it is at this point
very rare that I have a flatly masculine
day
they they are becoming less and less and
less frequent it's part of why I dropped
the masculine pronoun a year and a bit
ago
um because it used to be like all
pronouns are fine
um I'm fine with either she or they I
don't like being called he him
um because I don't really identify
um masculinely anymore that having been
said my sense of gender does still move
it is still fluid it does still waver
so it's still fluid it's just not
[Music]
um
wandering as much space so now it
basically goes from uh you know feminine
to non-binary and you know various sort
of minglings of the two
but I managed to
make this even murkier than it was
um but I I do still identify as gender
fluid
and I'm crucial to this is I do not
identify as a trans woman as I said I am
trans feminine so I am a trans Femme
that meaning that I have transitioned
because I am on hormones and
um you know and I flatly you know not
that you have to be on hormones to
transition but like I flatly don't
identify as the gender I was assigned at
Birth I am trans and I'm trans feminine
because I identify more as feminine than
as any degree of masculine so I am trans
and my transition has put me in a more
feminine place I am trans Femme but I'm
not a trans woman I don't identify as a
woman I don't claim to be a woman so
when the Jack has to show up in my
comments are like you'll never be a
woman
knocking stuff around I delete that with
the knowledge that like yeah I never
said I was
piss off
it's all about the Alistair Sim version
of Christmas Carol that one's really
good
um
the uh the George C Scott one's pretty
good as well
I also have I have I have a little bit
of a soft spot for the um
uh Patrick Stewart one which isn't great
but he's pretty good in it
I'm definitely planning to do more
karate classes oh good for you Kate I
hope you enjoy them
as the fluid concealed I guess a little
uh Gremlins is the movie that I have to
watch every year for Christmas that one
works see I I have a hard time watching
the first one because I like the second
one so much more
I had a rush of Christmas Nostalgia
yesterday when I went to a friend's
house and saw their Rankin bass
decorations
see it's funny like I love Rank and bass
but I love their fantasy stuff like I
don't think I'd seen any of their
holiday stuff until I was an adult but I
grew up on The Hobbit and The Last
Unicorn and Thundercats so
first time live chatting on my phone
laptop is at the technician still a bit
clumsy on the phone ah don't worry Gozer
you're doing just fine
I love Muppets Christmas Carol that one
like that one is it's a legitimately
good adaptation even Muppets aside it's
legitimately good
Edward Woodward as the Ghost of
Christmas present
so Dharma
uh I have a hard time seeing that name
because like
I've listened to the uh the audio
commentary on Hot Fuzz
and
um
one of the things they go off is
whenever Edward Woodward is is in the
shot they so they do a call back to I
guess what was an inside joke like what
would his name be if without the letter
d uh
and so whenever he's on screen they just
say and
so I have a hard time seeing uh Edward
Woodward's name without thinking
it's real dumb it's real stupid but
uh what are you gonna do have I ever
heard of the parody song
um 12 Pains of Christmas yes I'm I'm
quite familiar with that one I was
introduced to that song by my kiddo's
mother uh back when I was in my 20s
uh
the 12 Pains of Christmas I don't
remember all of them I remember the last
two you know the two and the one rigging
up the lights and finding a Christmas
tree yep
I haven't heard that in a while
I think the George C Scott version has
both the best Marley and best Ghost of
Christmas present Edward Woodward is
quite terrifying so like here's the
thing I grew the first version of
Christmas Carol I ever knew was Mickey's
Christmas Carol I I actually thought
that Pete as
um The Ghost of Christmas future was
damn terrifying
there's something about the laugh and
the casualness with which he lights up a
stub of a cigar and smacks Scrooge into
this open grave where the coffin opens
and it's the Flames of hell and he's
just up there laughing I I thought that
was damn scary when I was a kid
have I seen del Toro's Pinocchio it's a
wild ride I have not had the time I
don't know when I'm gonna get to that
wait Rankin bass did Thundercats yeah
they did
fun fact for you
Jules bass Jules Bass passed away at the
end of October yeah yeah that was a
bummer uh Arthur Rankin Jr had passed
away some years ago but yeah
let's be honest jingle all the way is my
go-to next to Grinch I won't accept any
negativity about that in fact I'll class
it as blasphemy
you do you it's fine
hate hate hate hate hate hate no the
entirely
I'll say this the Jim Carrey Grinch
is very memeable
it is a very mimetic movie
Strange World Star streaming December
23rd that fast holy crap
they abandoned that even faster than I
thought they would oh my gosh
Oh that's oh dear
oh dear
the Grinch Charlie Brown and Rudolph and
the Little Drummer Boy which requires a
box of tissues ah
I think I think a good a good cry does
you good
uh where did I leave off
the yes exactly Dharma
who's who's Lonesome grave is this why
are you Ebenezer the richest man in the
cemetery
freaked me out when I was a kid
ah
ah let's see do I watch Elf uh no I have
seen elf but it's not part of my uh my
regular
holiday diet like if somebody else puts
it on I'm not like gonna like turn it
off but it's not what I'm gonna go out
of my way to see
I got Vera vibes from the character
Ember from the teaser of Pixar's
Elemental
that that teaser didn't leave a huge
impression on me
but then again like to be fair early
teasers for Pixar movies rarely do so
that's not really indicative of
anything
four o'clock
I feel like I don't hold on I want to
look that up now I want to look up the
whole quote give me a give me a hot
second
dude
[Music]
all right here we go
even if I wanted to go my schedule
wouldn't allow it one o'clock wallow in
South pretty 4 30 stared into the abyss
five o'clock solve world hunger tell no
one
5 30 Jazzercise 6 30 dinner with me I
can't cancel that again seven o'clock
wrestle with myself loathing
I'm booked
and the thing is like I can like moments
like that in isolation I still don't
think they actually work in the context
of the movie like at all but
12 Pains of Christmas gets funnier when
he starts changing the verse to get the
flashlight and blew a fuse that is one
of the things I did like first time I
heard 12 Pains of Christmas that every
time it comes back to the light sky well
not every time but eventually it starts
being not just like ranking up by lights
it starts getting more more and more
annoyed get the flashlight I blew a fuse
now why the hell are they blinking one
light goes out they all go out yeah
let's see where was I
have I heard the song A Merry Christmas
kiss my ass I don't think I have I think
I've heard that one
uh
uh Angus thank you very much for the
Super Chat oh uh so we've got the
follow-up on the Maverick thing
the end of top gun Maverick
uh tale was they had no one locally to
get it to play
uh it uh
as it is all computerized and the
computer said no we were offered a
grumpy refund oh no oh
know how to hand digital
the digital projection oh geez
hmm
uh
can I try A Christmas Story I've seen A
Christmas Story I know A Christmas Story
there's nothing to try I've tried it
Nightmare Before Christmas is my go-to
Christmas movie and Halloween movie and
any of the time movie ah yes
one of the best films about cultural
appropriation
um did you see some of the new Berryman
stuff today if you don't want to talk
about it it's fine it's sad to see
um
I only like I know a little bit I know
I don't know what
um cause I don't know what happened that
made him think he should do this
but I know that John Barrowman put out a
tweet
um basically slamming
uh even miles his co-star from Torchwood
um it was a picture of the two of them
together and it said only one of the
people in this picture is telling the
truth
or something like that and
he must have realized that he uh he
really screwed up
uh in doing that because last I checked
his entire Twitter account has been is
gone has been shut down
um and it wouldn't have been by you know
Twitter itself it's something he would
have had to do voluntarily
um just shut the whole thing down and
yeah I
I I was I watched a little bit briefly
some of Mr tardis's stream from today he
covered it uh more thoroughly than I'm
going to
um or ever going to want to but
I feel like the short version of what
has happened with Barrowman is that
well first of all let's acknowledge that
wow what he did what he got in trouble
for doing was not okay and never was
let's start there
but the point at which it
came up in the conversation was for very
[ __ ] reasons because Noel Clark was
basically trying to pull a what about
ISM with him because he was facing a ton
of far worse allegations and basically
well what about that guy and dragged him
into the conversation so like the reason
it even came up was BS so to a certain
degree I understand why
he was frustrated about it but his
handling of that whole thing was just
really really bad because he never
really issued an apology once it came up
again he he did various things where he
said I've apologized for that in the
past but the reason that doesn't matter
is because like he apologized back in
like 2008 but there were more recent
incidents of him exposing himself on the
sets of shoots since then so that
apology effectively doesn't matter and
he never really apologized again since
then but what he basically if I were to
um
give my short version of what happened
was he went
oh
um yeah no I I guess that wasn't great I
guess I'm kind of start like it wasn't
even really apology but let's pretend
for a moment he's like yeah no I'm sort
of sorry about that and then when that
turned out to not be enough for people
to just go oh well it's all okay then he
just went hard the opposite direction
started going off on canceled culture
and how all of it's unfair and it's all
a joke it's all meant in good fun like
he he went from
walking right up to the line of
apologizing for it and then when it
turned out that he thought that was
going to be enough and it wasn't he just
went hard the other way and stopped
acting like there was anything to
apologize for and yeah that as John
Bainbridge said in the chat that feeling
when you cancel yourself
that's pretty much it
that is pretty much exactly what he did
at this point
at this point
any work he fails to get
any production that won't have him back
be it Doctor Who be it if they revive
Torchwood again please don't but if they
do be it anything related to the
arrowverse you know people not wanting
to work with him at this point is his
fault
there was a time a couple of years ago
where it was a little bit it like it I
even did a video at the time like it
felt a little weird at me that he was
losing work like with big finish
closer to when the initial sort of brew
HaHa happened because he hadn't he
hadn't gone full like I did nothing
wrong yet
um but he was still losing work so again
I do understand his frustration but at
this point
like people are just looking at his
behavior and going I don't want to work
with that guy and that he did that to
himself so like the initial loss of work
may may I'm not even sure I have to like
go back and look at the Timeline may
have not been entirely Fair
but the fact that it's ongoing and
hasn't resolved and you know is
something that still keeps coming up
that's his own damn fault at this point
and it's a shame it really is I
I wanted him to just do better than he
did because I met him and he was
charming and wonderful and I saw you
know one of his
um
sort of panel live show kind of things
at a at a conference and he was he was
delightful and it was really really
frustrating to just watch him
trip over his own feet again and again
and again
freaking again
ah
let's see I heard that's
about a cross uh Chris Muppets Christmas
Carol sweetums went into a violet rage
on set when he learned he wasn't going
to play the Ghost of Christmas present
come in and know me better man
yeah yeah that's pretty much it Gozer
John we were rooting for you and you
effed it up
yeah
pretty much like
here's the thing
it it it always feels weird
to say this about someone who is not
only accused but like we can comfortably
say did not good stuff but I feel like
at least in terms of
handling the aftermath
very few of them have done well and I'd
say the ones who probably did the best
was Warren Ellis and again this is not
to forgive Warren Ellis for anything he
did not saying anyone then I'm not even
saying he should start getting work
again but just in terms of not
not making the situation worse he
probably handled it about as well as it
could be handled because Warren Ellis
short version he is a television and
comic book writer and novelist he's
writing for all kinds of stuff he's
written a lot for Marvel
um he wrote transmetropolitan he wrote
all of the Netflix Castlevania uh
uh show
but he had
um some things some women came forward
about
um
how things went in relationships that
they had with him and what he did was he
immediately said
I don't think anyone should doubt these
women
he immediately walked away from every
project he had he wasn't fired from
anything he didn't have time to be fired
he walked away from everything he said
I'm going to go and you know get into
therapy and try and get myself sorted
because what these women say they
experienced is not my memory but he
didn't say that in a their lying way he
said that in a I clearly didn't
understand the dynamic that was actually
at play and he's basically kept his head
down ever since so far as I can tell I
don't think he's popped up again
um and again none of this is to say and
he's a good guy he's not
but like in terms of a if you want a
template
for how to not make the situation work
I feel like that's pretty much it
you know don't call anybody a liar and I
mean unless you honestly think
somebody's lying let's
let's put that caveat in there if you
honestly very sincerely believe that
somebody is targeting and lying about
you you know dig whatever put your feet
in the ground however you need to but
like if you know in your heart like I
don't think these people are lying don't
call anybody a liar don't make it a
bigger stink then
um it should be walk away from
everything so that you're not tainting
whatever creative projects you're
attached to and just
go sort yourself out
like
it's it's so weird to point to somebody
who like again I don't feel as a good
guy even though I have to admit to
having liked a lot of his work but and
go like
he kind of did it right
like Louis CK almost did it right and
then he came back with a with a comedy
special bitching about cancel culture I
was like oh yeah okay great
uh
anyways that turned into a longer longer
rant than I intended it to be
see the Santa hat in the background yeah
oh I'd use that for a shoot earlier and
I haven't put it away it's actually
sitting it is sitting on top of uh my
hip pads
oddly enough
um
so he's hot charming and toxic I'm
shocked shocked I say I'm shocked
shocked well not that shocked in case
you ever wanted to know what happened to
seven and Ace I'm gonna be reviewing the
books that picked up where the show left
out starting in January oh
that sneaky little plug for your channel
there although seriously vacuum of
comments does very nice work and and I
think if you follow me I think you would
enjoy uh Ben's stuff
let's see
you know the worst John Barrowman tried
to pee in the wind and it blew back in
his face yeah kinda
I can't hear that phrase without
thinking of um
oh what was it uh oh it was it was uh
Far and Away which is a a
90s movie I just remember a character
going up to another one like what do you
think you're doing pissing into the wind
huh
uh
let's see
venga Boys Are Back In Town ooh
that's boy there's a blast from the past
oh that's great
uh I remember first I saw the bearman
stuff is from a clip of a panel Clark
was part of where he mentioned bearman
stuff I don't think Clark brought
bearman down we just found out Clark was
bringing it up and was pointing to it
now like Berryman brought himself down
but the fact that the spotlight was put
on him that was kind of Clark's fault
uh
watch your reaction to Spider-Man into
the spider-verse it's not it's across
the spider verse but thank you yeah that
uh trailer reaction is up in the break
room of Geeks
foreign
I think that Society doesn't do CIS men
any favors and how they teach them to
treat women so I can appreciate a man
who says I didn't realize uh what I did
wasn't right so I'm going to work on it
yeah like again does not forgive
any of it
um but
you know it it's true Pirates
did you know
that we live in a society
think about it
anyways
um was it ship hell bringing Elon on
stage bad
that oh Caroline was the one who brought
that whole thing to my attention this
morning
[Laughter]
oh
I'm all right I'm all right
oh
that uh that was energizing this morning
oh Christmas hat Ground Zero that's
weird Weird Al uh has some interesting
Christmas songs because there's
Christmas background zero uh there's the
night sound went crazy don't play that
one for the kids
Yes Virginia now Santa's doing time in a
federal prison for his Infamous crime
uh
sorry
um
I I think it's the the second to last
chorus
and he smiled as he said with a twinkle
in his eye Merry Christmas to all now
you're all gonna die
oh Al Yankovic is he's
just the right amount of sick I I feel
like
[Music]
I can't believe my parents let me listen
to the Bingo boys those lyrics were
something else I think a lot of us at
various points
once we once we paid closer attention to
lyrics we were like
am I am I supposed to be listening to
this
my partner's way hyped for Wednesday I
hope you enjoy it
I've heard good things about it I I
don't know when I'll find the time
do you guys get the Christmas song
driving home for Christmas by Chris Raya
played over in America it's a Sublime
Christmas song I do not know that one
that does not ring a bell
uh
uh Bronco no it's not bronchitis like
I've just had I've just had this litter
this lingering this is what this is what
I tend to think of as like a clearing
cough like it's not I'm not sick anymore
but it's just like just trying to clear
that slight ant at the back because like
I feel
I feel fine I can breathe fine I'm not
I'm not sick it's just
hey
so like what was Chappelle's point and
all that I think Chappelle genuinely had
no idea that the crowd was going to be
so hostile I don't think he had a point
other than like hey
I'm friends with the rich God
dang it with the rich guy
I don't think he had a point beyond that
I just thought I just think he he
thought it like there's a famous guy in
the crowd let's just bring him up I
don't think he thought of it beyond that
foreign
hey Meg I didn't see you sneaking it's
good to see you
National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation is
an excellent Christmas movie that one is
quite good
that one is good I agree
hang on by a thread oh
oh Meg I'm sorry
the venga boys that's the name I've not
heard since actually a month ago in
Todd's top 10 90s buses list that was so
weird bless him for doing it
I sometimes wish Louis say hey continued
his pre- uh 2018 style of Comedy Maya
comedy minus the sexual assault and not
whine about canceled culture
I mean
so
here's
here's the thing that I'll say about
people
like
uh Louis CK and people in positions like
that
sorry
I think I've just hit this point where
this tickling my throat ideally I would
just stop stop talking for a bit but we
got 20 minutes left on the screen scream
stream stream
anyways
um so I think the thing with someone
like uh Louis CK is that
I understand to a certain extent
that
if he felt it was time for him to start
trying to work again or if financially
if he needed to which I don't know what
his financial situation was but you know
in theory
career-wise
he had one of two options
try to appeal to an audience that was
mad at him and maybe wasn't ready to
have him back yet
and who maybe was not going to be ready
to forgive him for who knows how long
God damn it
or
appeal to a different audience that will
absolutely take him in which is the
anti-wo cancel culture crowd
because that's the thing that position
is inherently right-wing and there are a
few things right Wingers love more than
someone who used to be either more
Center or Progressive leaning who is now
doing their dance and appealing to them
they love that it's really hard to go
the other direction
more progressively minded people tend to
be very suspicious and cautious of
someone who has a history of
exemplifying the other end of the
spectrum
foreign
but going the other way
that's basically guaranteed money so
either could have like pounded the
pavement and grinded himself down trying
to win back the audience he lost or he
could appeal to a new one he chose the
latter I don't like it
but I get it
ah
finally got around to watching Tokyo
Godfathers today I still haven't seen
that one
uh we've been given our parts of the
Nativity Play and I'm the lobster the
lobster yeah
in the Nativity Play yeah first Lobster
there was more than one Lobster at the
birth of Jesus
duh
um
have I seen the animated film the
Snowman I have but not since I was a kid
I don't understand how anyone on the
left could turn conservative that just
doesn't compute for me well nine times
out of ten
it's going well okay no let me revise
that in my experience
it's one
it's one of three things
Vera please drink some water
thank you mag
but so people on the left gravitating
towards the right tends to be one of a
couple of things
firstly you have
um
basically just self-interest
it will be more beneficial to them
personally
to go over to the right
this is where I lumped together most
um people who like
basically all of the hippies who became
yuppies all the hippies in the 60s who
became yuppies in the 80s this is them
they
um they realized that there was more
money in being on the right and so they
just went that way because it paid
better
so that's one the other and this also
kind this one kind of skews older is
you'll have people who
their positions have basically never
moved but
um the what the left considers
Progressive has gone further left than
they are and they kind of become some
degree of conservative by default and
then they look around and go well I
guess I have more in common with these
people on the right and so they go that
way
um
and I had another one had another reason
in my head and now it's gone
but I think a lot of it oh well the
other one just being
um
there is one specific hardcore Prejudice
that they have that is so strong they'll
sacrifice everything else
this is like where you get so you know
someone who really really hates gay
people and maybe otherwise
is you know accepting of various
religions you know isn't uh isn't
especially racially
um harsh uh or anything you know
believes in Social programs but just
really hates gay people if you hate that
enough
you have to go to the right because the
left supports them even if everything
else is antithetical to your views
actually I think a better
um
point of reference on that might be the
abortion issue that was a big wedge
issue
and okay so now I'm gonna go off on
another thing so just stick with me
this is part of the problem
of
um
having only two parties and then being
around for as long as the Democrats and
the Republicans have because they just
settle on basically being on the
opposite side of almost every issue
there are a handful of things that they
basically agree on but all of like the
big let's have a debate about this
issues they are on opposite sides of
gun control abortion queer right you
know queer rights how much religion
should be in our public institutions etc
etc it's opposite sides and that's just
where they're going to drift to over
time if those two parties don't get
shaken up
they're going to drift on the opposite
sides of these issues but what that
means is that for any individual for
whom they don't line up 100
with one or the other
they're going to have to make a decision
and basically prioritize and rank their
values
so in theory
if you are socially Progressive
but financially conservative which most
people say they are that are just
conservative across the board but like
just indulge the thought if you believe
that
um
we should have smaller government but do
not believe in any way in stripping away
the rights from queer people you believe
in the right to abortion you believe in
all this other stuff well one party
serves one set of needs the other serves
the other the uh the Log Cabin
Republicans are the perfect example of
this because they were a bunch of
white CIS gay men who completely agreed
um with
basically everything the Republican
party did but when the Republican party
was trying to push to get
um uh marriages between a man and a
woman added to the Constitution they
basically went look we we are not okay
with this but we're okay with everything
else
they may have objected to that but they
still voted Republican they wanted
different Republican candidates who
wouldn't push for that specific issue
but they still vote a Republican
so that is the situation that we find
ourselves in
where and then once you're in that
situation
you have one of two choices
either
you have to deal with the fact
that you're never going to be completely
happy because the party that either
addresses most of your political needs
or the biggest political needs whichever
might be the case
is still not going to align with you
absolutely 100 you have to you just have
to reconcile that fact that on some
issues you are voting for people who
aren't going to do what you want them to
do
and that's frustrating and annoying and
infuriating or
you can basically go in really hard and
go
okay
so I'm already voting this way because
of these core things
maybe it just makes more sense for me to
just back all these positions because
this is the way I'm going to vote
regardless
I don't think that's necessarily a
conscious choice that people make but I
do think
um
I do think that it is a it is a shift
that happens
it's kind of the political equivalent of
you know if you're gonna treat me like
I'm an [ __ ] I'm gonna act like one
so if you are going to treat me like I
believe all these things because I vote
this way
even though I'm only voting this way
because of these specific issues if
you're going to treat me as if I'm in
favor of all of this well screw it I'll
just be in favor of all of it
and that's how you get it drifting
further and further further further
further
um to either give inside
though usually further to the right left
radicalization I'm not going to say it
doesn't exist it does but it's not as uh
it is not as well constructed a pipeline
uh 255 A.D how long I'd have to wait if
I pick uh culture no audio
um
all right realistically you'd probably
be looking at some time in the summer
uh tail end of the summer so July
realistically
could I get to it before then maybe but
I can't promise that
I'm not even going to guarantee you that
some of them just realistically I think
that's about where it lands
hmm
Discord thank you carowind all right so
I will be back in just a moment
I've got to pop over to the Council of
Geeks Discord which is indeed a patreon
perk so you can uh join the Council of
Geeks patreon to get access to that
don't have too many questions this time
so this should be quick
um okay this is somebody
um
laying out some either ORS for me
best Christmas movie Muppet Christmas
Carol or Die Hard
Muppet Christmas Carol's the better
Christmas movie
if you're asking me the better movie
overall that's tougher but if you're
saying best Christmas movie it's mother
Christmas Carol I'm sorry it is
uh best Santa Richard Attenborough or
Nick Frost Nick Frost Nick Frost was an
awesome Santa Richard Attenborough was a
good Santa he was a good Santa don't get
me wrong
I like mcfrost a little better
uh best Christmas special Charlie Brown
Christmas or Charlie Brown Christmas uh
Garfield Christmas
so there you go
all right I'm back I'm back in the uh
the main chat now
uh what's my favorite version of A
Christmas Carol
um
I mean I've definitely seen them Muppet
one more than any of the others
I I'm not I don't have a strong
commitment uh on it though that subject
kind of came up earlier in the uh in the
Stream
Richard Ambrose from my hometown oh cool
are you saying we need an LGBT
capitalist libertarian party and a
socially conservative tanky party no
I do think we need a third party of some
form
so that
the and like
third part unfortunately third parties
are not realistic going to get a big
foothold what is I think the only major
way that is likely to happen is if one
of the parties has a has a foundational
split
um but then what is more likely to
happen is one version will
die out and the other will continue on
um
but I
the the problem with two parties
specifically is it it just it just
stratifies
either side of every issue whereas if
you had a third party you'd have a
reason for there to be more nuanced
you'd you'd have a reason to take a
position other than the opposite of the
opposing party because if the opposing
party has a position
it's in your political interest to take
the opposite position to appeal to
everybody that they are taking off and
that's just what happens
thoughts on fairy tale of New York apart
from that verse I don't think I know
fairy tale of New York or if I do I'm
not I'm drawing a blank
would I ever get a Charlie Brown
Christmas tree Now by Charlie Brown
Christmas tree do you mean the big metal
one or the little tiny like you put one
ornament and goes one
uh in either case probably not
um
have I seen Nan's Christmas Carol
Catherine Tate discouraged David tennis
the Ghost of Christmas present I've not
seen that
yes Gozer I I found out about that on
Twitter today so yes David Tennant has
taken to wearing a non-binary
um patterned
uh rainbow pin uh in public and in
interviews like on um Zoom interviews
and whatnot
um
because one of his kids is non-binary
and
I love that
I love that and I I love I remember
seeing the comments on somebody who
brought it up and like there were
multiple pictures of him with this pin
and one of the comments was you know at
first I thought maybe he had just fixed
it uh you know affixed it to one
specific jumper and it just stayed there
but then I saw that same pin on various
different shirts and sweaters and
jumpers and whatnot is like that means
he's making a point it's not just
something that's there and that's the
that's the sweater he happened to put on
he's making a point of wearing it
publicly invisibly
which is great that's great
my first Christmas Carol was Mickey's
Christmas Carol same
goes through Christmas future uh was
just as traumatizing as the Bill Murray
version
that one's pretty scary too
uh fairy tale of New York is the song at
the start of the Guardians Christmas
special that's
that okay I think I missed that because
the song when I think of the song at the
start of
the guardian's Christmas special
um
when I say that or I think of that I'm
referring to I don't know what Christmas
is
um
so no I don't know this other one
have I seen Arthur Christmas I saw it
once was cute
I know some other people like I know
cell specs swears by it
um and it's fine it's fine
I love Rise of the Guardians a little
obsessed with the concept of Jack Frost
also love Frost and the Laurel K
Hamilton books Jack Frost like
he's become
um he's accumulated a lot of simps over
over the years like a lot of people ship
him with Elsa and it's kind of adorable
uh
uh Rise of the Guardians is so good too
though never quite sure when to watch it
I'm not sure I've seen the entire thing
front to back I think I even have it
I think I think like my kid watched it
I've seen most of it
I don't I don't know if I've seen the
whole thing
uh anyways
uh
where was I
have you been able to get Little Debbie
Christmas tree cakes I can't find them
anywhere I I generally try not to get
that kind of stuff because I I eat too
much of it
I hope you have a great Christmas with
your family thank you Brendan I
appreciate that
Little Debbie trees are out oh
I also saw a weird chocolate variant ooh
not ideal
uh
uh oh so I guess there's a line in this
song that everyone's referring to about
the NYPD choir
um again I like I don't think I actually
like I obviously I've heard the song if
it was in the guardian special I heard
it but like I don't think it stood out
to me I don't think I actually know it
so we keep we keep coming back to the
song that I don't really
no
what were your opinions on Elon Musk pre
2019
I don't know if I gave enough of a crap
about him to have an opinion
to be honest
uh I don't think it was high I don't
think I've ever thought I
I don't think I've ever thought
particularly highly of billionaires I
didn't start to truly sour on them until
I don't know
2017 2018 ballpark
maybe even a little before that
no it would have been before that let's
say 2015 2015 I started to sour on that
and at this point I'm just on the uh the
fact that billionaires exist is
unethical
um train but I don't think I was ever
impressed with Elon Musk I don't think I
ever drank the Kool-Aid on that one
flavor eight if we want to be technical
about it
255 A.D thank you very much for the
Super Chat my fave uh and the whole
series look to win word I thought about
commissioning another for Christmas you
could get to more easily but not my fave
I mean whatever you want to do is up to
you but like keep in mind at this point
especially I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
get to any more commissions before
Christmas like I'm I'm actually getting
way ahead on my shooting I'm like months
ahead on my shooting so like
even if you were to commission me
immediately
like
and even if it was something I could do
like in a day like real quick it's not
gonna go up
uh for at least a month if not two
minimum
so
have I heard of strange Hill High no
I don't think so
if I've heard of it I've forgotten
Christmas movie recommendation Anna and
the apocalypse a diamando reviewed it
recently it's a Scottish High School
Musical Christmas zombie movie isn't
that the one with Anna Kendrick
I do like her
while I like Torchwood I don't want it
back as a show I would like to see a
return to the original concept of uh
from series two an earth organization
that's hostile to the doctor
um I mean maybe like
I don't think Torchwood was ever
especially good other than children of
Earth it was sporadically good
uh uh and children of Earth was great
and other than that I'm like why why are
we doing this
have I seen the Santa Claus I've seen
the original movie I have not seen
either of the sequels or the series
foreign
have I ever seen sausage party nope and
I do not intend to
ever
like if somebody commissions me and
wants me to rip into it yeah sure fine
spend your money how you want to spend
your money I will not voluntarily ever
watch sausage party for multiple reasons
am I the only one who wasn't a massive
fan of Gwen Cooper she never did much
for me if I'm honest like she's fine
she's not a bad character I didn't
dislike her but like I she wasn't a pole
for me
have I seen the Christmas Chronicles
it's on Netflix no my mother saw that
it was good I have not look to one word
is 357 Pages yeah that's going to be
some months
um to get to that
um
Just Gonna Stand in to play Jack with
his face
mutating into that of the face of a bow
have the doctor take him to the Future
put him in that jar
laughs
uh
just like I won't ever voluntarily watch
Glee exactly
Suggs with a box thank you that's very
generous for that Super Chat happy
holidays and happy holidays to you as
well thank you I appreciate that greatly
my favorite sonic screwdriver
um
I'm not sure like
of of the ones I have Recreations of
which is most of them
um
I kind of just like messing around with
12s the most I think aesthetically I
like Rivers best though
uh would I rather watch sausage party or
Glee well sausage party only because
it's shorter it's 90 minutes as opposed
to multiple seasons of Television so
uh
let's see
uh
I think we are going to wrap it up soon
do I ever plan on going to Turf Island
no
no I don't
I
I wouldn't feel safe
setting foot in the UK
like I would maybe feel slightly safer
than going to certain Southern States
like let me put it this way
I'd probably feel safer in the UK than I
wouldn't say Texas
um or Utah
but
that doesn't mean I'd feel safe there
objectively I'd just be slightly less
awful so no I
I might I might in future
[Music]
um
go well I'll tell you what if Scotland
ever goes independent I'll go there in a
heartbeat I might go to Scotland anyway
at some point but yeah
um I've been to England I had a
wonderful trip there
years and years and years and years ago
but I do not want to go back
yeah anyways Supreme Omega thank you
very much for the super chat
um I know you want Tim to be adapted how
would you adapt his main love interest
Steph aka the spoiler also Cass Kane
because those two girls never get
adapted well uh Cassandra Kane
technically did get adapted but like the
character born or resembles so he might
as well not count it
um I don't
know Stephanie Brown especially well if
I'm being honest the thing is with
Cassandra Kane so I feel like for
Cassandra came to work
you do need the base level of Robin
having been a thing Robin does not
necessarily mean need to currently be a
thing Batgirl does not need to have been
a thing previously I don't think you
need Barbara in order to do Cassandra
Kane because honestly her
um origin and her pull towards the bat
family and her pull towards all that
does not require that Batgirl is an
existing mantle that she takes up
she could totally build it for herself I
think the only thing you need to
establish is that Batman has had some
degree of protege before because I think
it's gonna be too hard to sell that like
he just his his conclusion of uh what do
we do with this severely uh traumatized
um and dangerous uh young woman
um oh I know I'll help train her to
fight crime and hopefully teach her to
not kill people without having some
precedent that he's done something like
this before I think it just becomes a
bizarre decision but as long as you and
you don't even necessarily to have shown
as long as you can establish that bat
that Robin has been the thing at least
once before you can just do Cassandra
Kane pretty much as is
anyways
I think we are going to wrap it up
um
head up Stephanie Sterling they uh look
out for you over there I don't doubt
that um that they would maybe like I
like I know I've talked with Steph once
but like it we did just talk once it was
it was basically just you know an
interview but
um they're lovely stuff's great
what if I commission one review at
Christmas but another one at March my
birthday that you can get on audiobook
would you get to the latter one first
um
[Music]
I feel like this is a conversation that
might be better had over email uh 255
A.D
um
just in general
like here's the thing I have my goals
for trying to catch up on the backlog of
commission reviews because it is a
backlog so
I I understand your desire to have stuff
addressed quickly and I certainly would
like to get to it faster than I have in
the past but I am not right now in a
position to make guarantees on time
frames I'm just not I can give you my
best guess I can give you a goal I
cannot make you promises and you know
giving me more specific uh scenarios of
well okay well what if this and this and
I ask for this like
I can't promise you I can promise you
that I it will get done but I cannot
promise you a time frame I have too much
going on and I am too behind on other
commissions to be able to promise you a
time frame
okay
I'm I'm doing my best
but I I just you're asking for something
that I can't give right now
all right Supreme Omega in with one last
Super Chat also in cast do you need to
adapt no man's land no
no you don't have to I mean
you all you have to do is establish that
um Gotham City is bad enough that
somebody would behave in the way she is
behaving and would take up that mantle
and do that stuff and you don't
necessarily need no man's land to
justify that just have Gotham be that
bad
um anyways okay so stuff coming up
tomorrow
um I'll be on Twitch 10 30 a.m Eastern
Standard Time
um and uh that I will be playing uh just
just a little to the left or like a
little to the left something like that
it's basically just just to chill out
and relax kind of game I'll be doing
that
um I am not planning to do any more
um Episode by episode uh reviews
it's Yule reviews of uh Willow so don't
expect that
um but there will be more stuff going up
in the break room during the week
um Friday I'll be on Twitch again
probably playing more of the same
um
Saturday
uh Saturday's video is going to be
interesting
um I'm going to be
talking about how we discuss
mental health in relation to public
figures
and I'm going to launch into this
conversation by way of JK Rowling
so
that'll be
that'll be interesting
um so that's that Saturday
um and I think that's everything coming
up this week Monday's more jump gate and
um yeah next stream will be next stream
here will be the 27th so it'll be after
uh Christmas and it'll be the last one
of this of 2022
and I think that is
everything
all right
thank you everybody for uh tuning in
thank you for your thoughts your well
wishes the super chats always
appreciated and I hope that you have a
great rest of the week and please
remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
my cavity